- A lot has already been
written about Elon Musk.
He lives his life between the tweets,
upended, reinvented the auto industry,
aerospace, now trying it
with Twitter turned X.
You spent two years shadowing him.
What did you learn that
we didn't already know
about Elon Musk?
- Well, there's certainly
multiple Elon Musks,
multiple personalities.
Whether it's a hardcore engineering mode
that you know so well,
where he can figure out
how to do a battery cell,
or more importantly,
figure out how to do steps
on an assembly line that
will make the battery cell.
But also, there's almost
a demon mode of Elon Musk,
where he turns really dark.
And that can be very problematic,
especially when it came
to acquiring Twitter,
which I think involves more
emotional intelligence.
- Are there ground rules,
anything off limits?
Did you sleep on the
factory floor next to him?
(Walter laughing)
- You know, I slept in Airstream trailers
down in the south tip of Texas
where SpaceX has its launchpad.
I spent a lotta late nights in factories.
He put nothing off limits,
which surprised the heck out of me.
I mean, meetings that were
about forward-looking products,
everything else, he said,
"I just wanna surprise you
about the transparency."
And my side of the deal was,
"Fine, I wanna be everywhere,
but you get no control over the book.
You don't even get to read
it before it comes out."
- You've written a lot of books.
"Steve Jobs," biography was maybe,
perhaps, an instant classic.
And in that book, you
talk about the challenge
of breaking through
the Apple co-founder's
reality distortion field.
With Musk, you had extraordinary access.
By my count, you talked to more
than 120 people around him,
close deputies, even family
members, his father even.
Did you worry about that
reality distortion field
that he has, the fact
that he can sometimes be
an unreliable narrator in his own life?
- Well, yes, he can be unreliable,
and his memory is fallible
and he sort of cloaks himself
as a hero in every tale.
But I didn't feel a
reality distortion field.
He was not, he almost was
unaware of my presence,
it seemed, a lot of the time.
'Cause he'd be being a real jerk to people
at a meeting or blow
up on a walk around one
of the rocket sites.
And I'd think, "Wait a
minute, doesn't he know
I'm taking notes here?"
So it did surprise me
how open and in some ways
not trying to sugar coat things he was.
- You spent a really
significant part of the book
in the beginning talking
about his childhood
and his relationship with his father.
What was the early days of Elon Musk like?
- You know, he was a scrawny
kid, socially awkward,
beaten up on the playground a whole lot,
went to a wilderness camp,
in which, you know, sort of the survival.
And he lost 10 pounds in a week
because they kept beating
him up and taking his food.
But when he went back
to the wilderness camp
a few years later, he had gotten bigger.
He had learned a little judo, and he said,
"I just learned to
punch people in the nose
as hard as I could when
they were being mean to me.
And sometimes they'd beat me up,
but if I punched them
really hard in the nose,
they wouldn't do it again."
You almost see that nowadays,
which is he's pugnacious.
He sometimes can be so confrontational,
and when in doubt, he punches in the nose.
- You talk about his
relationship with his father.
His father is almost described
like a Jekyll and Hyde-like character.
Sometimes he can be friendly,
sometimes he can be volatile.
I've never seen him go so in-depth
about that childhood experience.
Why do you think he was
ready to talk about it now?
- It took a long time
for Musk to wanna talk
about his childhood.
I just sat there, I'd raise
it every now and then,
and sometimes we'd get to a place
where suddenly, he'd start
talking about his father.
And he would go, get teary-eyed at times,
very, very emotional, and just say,
"You don't know how bad the abuse was."
And after awhile, Elon
just kept opening up
about the psychological scars he had
when his father would make him
stand in front of his father
and yell at him for more than an hour
and take the sides of the
people who had beaten up Elon
and call Elon stupid.
- You write that, "The
PTSD from his childhood
also instilled in him an
aversion to contentment."
What do you think that
means for the companies
that he runs?
What does that mean for the
people that work for him
as they try to reach the goals
and sometimes achieve those goals?
- He's addicted to drama.
He's addicted to risk.
And whenever things seem
to be going smoothly,
he almost has a compulsion
to stir things up.
It allows him to become
a disruptive figure,
but also a difficult leader.
- What do you think was
one of the most surprising
kind of instances of him losing his temper
with one of his employees?
- Oh, one night in South Texas
at the launchpad of SpaceX,
it's a Friday night at 10:00 p.m.
And everything's going smoothly.
There's no launches being scheduled.
And he looks and there's
only two people working
at the launchpad.
And all of a sudden, I
see demon mode coming in,
almost like storm clouds
from the Gulf of Mexico.
And I'm thinking, "Well, it's
Friday night at 10:00 p.m."
And yet, he just reams
out this guy named Andy
who was in charge of the launchpad site.
And he orders a surge.
He orders 100 people to
come in from different parts
of SpaceX, from Florida, California,
so they can all work for 24 hours a day
getting this thing done,
even though there was no need to.
- What is demon mode in your mind?
- It's almost like Dr.
Jekyll and Mr. Hyde.
Where a cloud comes over
and he gets into a trance,
and he can just be tough in a cold way.
He never gets really angry,
never gets that physical,
but coldly brutal to people.
And he almost doesn't remember
afterwards what he's done.
Sometimes I'll say, "Why did
you say that to that person?"
And he'll look at me blankly,
as if he didn't quite
remember what happened
while he was in demon mode.
(crowd yelling)
Now, one of the things that
Claire Boucher, known as Grimes,
says is, "You don't wanna be around him
when he's in demon mode.
It's really frightening," she said.
But then she added, "But demon
mode is what gets shit done."
- Given all of the stories
about how he treats people,
why do you think he still has the ability
to attract talent to his companies?
- I talked to some of the
people on the Autopilot team
at Tesla when they were
doing Optimus, the robot.
And a couple of 'em had quit
because it was just too
brutal dealing with him,
and they got burned out.
But then one of 'em was back.
I said, "What happened?"
He said, "I decided I had a
choice between being burned out
or being bored and I decided
I wanted to be burned out
because I believed in the mission."
So some survive, but a whole lot don't.
- Another key one of the ways
of how he tries to manage
or how we kinda tries
to think about the world
is something he calls first principles,
which is essentially a problem-solving way
to not take what's been done in the past
as the way it should
be done in the future.
As trying to reach the ultimate goal
of whatever you're setting out,
kind of getting to the root problem
and figuring it out from there.
But that's very abstract.
It's kind of hard to put that,
understand what he means by that,
but it seems as if by
sitting around with him,
you've kind of seen the way he's trying
to impart that decision-making
framework to people
with something called the algorithm.
What is the algorithm?
- The algorithm is a five-step process
for not only making good products
and designing good products,
but manufacturing them.
And you're right.
It begins with first principles.
He says, "Question every requirement."
And by first principles,
he means look down at the physics.
If somebody says, "No, we
can't build it at this price,"
he says, "Tell me how
much the materials cost.
Tell me exactly what's involved here.
And then, tell me you can or can't do it."
When he first was trying
to buy a rocket booster
in Russia early on,
and they were charging him
$15 million or something,
on the flight home, he
calculated how much is the cost
of materials and fuel, and he said,
"Okay, those are the first principles.
We should be able to make
it at a much cheaper cost."
With the algorithm, he's always saying,
"Question every requirement.
And then delete, delete, delete."
So he simplifies things.
And then, only then do
you start to speed up
the manufacturing process,
and eventually, automate it.
One of his big mistakes at Tesla
was he went to automation too quickly
before he had deleted every part
and questioned every requirement.
- Do you see him moving into a new era
where he's essentially
seeding a bunch of ideas,
almost a Thomas Edison character,
putting money towards bigger ideas
and letting smart people invent it?
Or is he gonna kinda keep
control like a Henry Ford
back in the day of making sure
the Model T was the Model T
for as long as possible?
- Well, I think one of his
weaknesses, I'll call it,
is he really is a control freak.
You want him to give up control.
Say of Twitter, you're thinking,
"Okay, Linda Yaccarino should run it."
But he doesn't really
cede too much control.
Gwynne Shotwell at SpaceX
learns how to deal with him.
He really is focused on the product.
She gets to run the company.
But no, I don't see him
giving up a lotta control
over these companies, even
though they're are now
six or seven of 'em,
depending on how you
count, that he's running.
- Are we in the final act
of this kind of narrative?
Has he peaked?
Is he on the decline?
I would say that, for many years,
people have predicted his
kinda the epic collapse
of something, and he's been
able to get through it.
Is this just another example of that?
- Some of 'me are gonna collapse.
It's gonna be like his rocket
ships and everything else.
He believes you can't get into orbit
without blowing things
up every now and then.
So there will be debris.
There will be things blown up.
But I think, you know,
most things he's done
keep surprising me as being successful.